if you are a first-time visitor to
perrump likely the first thing you'll
notice is a very scenic road highway 160
also the shortest route between las
vegas and death valley
and as sally jalamillo reports it's
getting noticed for something else
one of the things that we could do here
in our town to make us a more tourist
attraction
is to put a winery in 1988 jack sanders
owners of sanders family
winery filed for a federal license to
make wine
in nevada param valley vineyards was the
rotation of that
before sanders sold it in 2005.
while many may only know of that winery
in perum new locations have started to
pop up
we wanted people to have a touch of
tuscany
a touch of italy and really not have to
travel too far
to visit sanders family winery has an
amazing view of mount charleston from
the other side that we see
in las vegas right next door to us is a
pistachio farm
you'll enter into the winery in through
the
courtyard through our amphitheater where
we actually do shows
and there is some history too there's
the original winery that i started
is parum valley winery then there is
artesian cellars and there's a stonewise
meadery
we do white wines we do red wines rose
wines
even champagne wine tasting is free and
bottles range between
10 and 16 you can get the most perfect
photo you want no matter where you are
whether it's in front of our statue at
the
entrance whether it's the entrance to
the amphitheater and the winery
just the building itself is tuscan
provincial
studies 8 news now
and just keep in mind the winery does
not sell food but you can bring your own
grab a picnic basket and bring it and
pets are also welcome christian